[Music]
is this true there's a lot of i talk to
a lot of celebrities who actually read
what people tweet about them or say
about them online i don't want to i
always advise don't do that do you do
that do you look at stuff that people
say about you online it can be hurtful
and then you can end up in a straight
jacket in a corner so you can help yeah
um but yeah i've made the mistake of
doing that and um i have a
a situation here
i have a vein that pops out vein
okay and
i'm trying to make it do it now yeah
[Music]
okay
okay
is it there is it there no i don't think
so uh like did you bring did you bring
up no i don't think there is a photo of
me
there
okay people
i'm sorry ladies and gentlemen
right here
thank you like it's the elephant man
and she also had two thugs and headlocks
yeah
she was foiling a robbery at that photo
no it's it's unfortunate oh okay you are
in fairness transforming into the hulk
i wish just one day but i know that tmz
how i saw it was actually um
this this um gossip tv show called tmz
oh yeah everyone knows that everyone
knows that they they showed it and they
pl they showed me walking in in
different um areas in in around town
with my vein and they played you're so
vain oh my god and you saw that yes and
then i went to my doctor and apparently
you need it to live because i was going
to try to have a minute
you're going to have you know it's funny
because i i relate to this i have this
irish skin and you can see my whole
skeleton on a bright day walking down
the beach and i have an eye that i have
an eye vein i know
i know you didn't
[Music]
in fact is everyone talking about it
get in there get that eye vein i'm not
afraid it's right there yeah there it is
right there now in the audience
you can't see this the audience
i like that they were fine with my vein
and you know what it was audience the
women were like
but there was a cute man who did it the
loudest that's
hard to hear well anyway the thing is
i've had this eye vein and i've actually
i remembered once i was talking to mike
wallace from 60 minutes and he like
leaned over
interviewing he said are you thinking of
getting rid of that and touched it they
touched my eye vein
temporarily cutting off blood to my
brain
see that we do need them to live no i
can't have that removed no no these are
going to stay yeah
at least and i think you're beautiful by
the way i'm going to go on i mean
everyone does you should gorgeous
and i think
i just did what happened there i looked
away for a second what were you doing
i did what's known as an air french kiss
i made it up
[Laughter]
can i see that again because i oh
then i'm not guilty of actually doing it
okay it's like the air guitar oh yeah
sure right
i digress anyway
this tv show is broken
there are lawyers from sizzler
dermatologist is on the line we can't do
anything about it yes you can what i
asked what can i do about my iv you can
have them dyed and discolored but i
decided you know what own your veins and
you should too
okay i will that's a by the way
quite possibly the saddest public
service announcement i've ever heard
i'm kristen chenoweth own your veins
kids
what own them at least they're not here
but that's fine too if you haven't
[Music]
i was at scissor the other day and i
saw this lady with a hip vein uh
my parents are gonna be so proud when
they watch the show my
my parents watch this every night
they're just suicidal
[Laughter]
why couldn't he be a
lawyer stupid uh